[Ruffles through desk]
[Slams remote]
The war is already won.
I found a loophole in the Pewdiepie vs T-Series war.
What?
Nani
"Youtube music is at 105 million subscribers..."
Who the hell is Pewdiepie's wage slave?
[Laugh]
"...so T-Series would not be the first channel to get 200 million..."
"...but Pewdiepie would be the first..."
"...youtuber to get to 1 million."
[Cheers]
Holy heck guys! This changes everything!
Oh my god!
[Mockingly] We win by default.
Well we still have to hit a hundred million.
Brofist at a hundred million.
"If Pewds starts a family, we would have 3 pies, Pewdiepie, Cutiepie, and the kid would be named?"
"Creampie."
[Silence]
Now hol-
"Visited a historical place today."
[Laugh]
Oh.. You found just a spot didn't you?
People are visiting from all across the world to b-be at this holy spot.
What video did you make this week that you're proud of? Share below.
The one you demonetized.
Cool.
You basically still put my name all over any Panda's tweet.
[Laughs]
Everyone's like: "it's against... it's big corporations versus..."
"... individuals."
Meanwhile me, big creator, stomping over these smaller Youtubers.
[Laughs]
"I cracked the system..."
"Did you know if Felix puts a giant watermark on screen whenever he says something..."
"...controversial, stating this was taken out of context, the media cannot use it as evidence."
No, they'll just use it as a quote, anyway.
Listen, I'm not trying to get on the hectic media rhetoric.
But they can just take whatever as a quote and say that's it.
It's not like they're gonna be "Oh there was a watermark on this saying that it was out of context."
"Turns down quality to 240p to save mobile data"
"Youtube: Loads 2 minute ad in 1080p and 60fps."
[Laughing] "My data plan:"
This is so sad.
I am crying in a nutshell.
"If you don't get this you all are going to hell."
"Stop dating boys who don't understand this."
Okay...
Bob.
[Window's Shut Down Tone]
[Silence]
What is that?
[Suspenseful Music]
Vegan- ah...
Witch...
Ever...
Will...
It...
Bee...
[Laughs]
Sit the frick down.
"This game is still relevant..."
NUMBER ONE IN TRENDING FOR GAMING?!
Holy heck guys.
That's it from now on, I'm a Happy Wheels gamer.
A hundred episodes.
Let's go gamers!
"Modern problems require older solutions."
[Laughs]
More Happy Wheels coming soon, and then Minecraft, and then more Happy Wheels.
We're go-gonna go full loop on this channel.
We're gonna go back to the call of duty commentaries.
"When you clap your hands two times but no one in your friend group screams MEME REVIEW!"
YES!!! [Laughs]
"Stepped on holy ground."
There it is... another... another pilgrimage.
From another nine-year-old.
Thank you. Very cool.
"Avengers deleted scene."
[Laughs]
Thanos ass looks like ass implants if the silicone was turned upside down.. if you've seen those videos?
I-i'm disappointed.
I thought Thanos was thick.
"When you were supposed to have memes running on you but nobody cares anymore."
"Sad static noises."
STOP CRYING
This guy will reach 100 mil one day and 1.3% of the population will be subbed to him.
Jesus Christ.
What is wrong with our planet?
Is there nothing more important happening right now?
Is that when we hit 8 million? Someone commented that?
This man was from the future.
He predicted the future.
You know when we hit 60, that's when things started goin- feeling ridiculous to me.
That's when I went like, okay, a-at this point I'm just seeing how far we can push it.
Hundred mil? Jesus f*cking Christ.
"Can we get the same likes as dislikes?"
Can this video get same likes as dislikes.
[Laughs]
It's still going!
"So perfectly balanced... as all things should be."
[Laughs]
Oh yeah, it's almost hit a million!
Damn, if this can hit one mil- ah- ten million views at the same time it hits a million comments...
...that would be lit as frick. Here you go proves Ricardo is the best girlfriend average build Ricardo rip this
"Here you go, proves Ricardo is the best."
"Girlfriend, average build."
"Ricardo, ripped AF."
"Girlfriend, needs constant attention."
"Ricardo, only has attention to give."
"Girlfriend, clean shaven face."
"Ricardo, God-like goatee."
That's right.
If your girlfriend doesn't have a goatee it's time to yeety that girl, go away-tee.
"Girlfriend, usually wears a shirt."
Excuse me, girl never wore the shirt in his life!
"Has okay tits."
[Laughs]
"Ricardo, has monster pecs."
"Takes an hour to prepare hair."
"Bandana welded into his skull."
[Laughs]
"Girlfriend, new Superman abilities."
"Ricardo, immortal, bends the universe at his will"
Ricardo, the only man who can defeat Thanos.
If he doesn't appear in End Game Marvel, whatever that movie is called...
...then I'm going to have to make "Why I Don't Like Marvel Movies Part 2."
That's right.
The most controversial video I have ever uploaded on this channel.
"Pewdiepie is the only wrapper in history to write a diss track so fire he got banned from a continent..."
"...thus making him the greatest rapper of all time."
[Silence]
[Laugh]
2019.. uhm.
It never fails to amaze me.
"Hey Time magazine, I fixed your list."
"If a person who has gotten billionaires to talk memes, raised hundreds of thousands for charity..."
"...and started a worldwide movement to subscribe doesn't make your list, it's not a very good list."
Damn MatPat with the support.
Thank you very much. That's really sweet of you.
I understand, Time.
The-they can't acknowledge people they feel like are doing something negative. Doing something negative
At least that was that's how interpret it.
Well Donald Trump is on it so.
"Felix: Get Pewdiepie's Dad to tell us embarrassing childhood stories."
"Felix: he has none, because I was the perfect child in every single way possible."
"Pewds Mom: We used to call you Felicia because you liked dressing up as a girl when you were a kid."
[Silence]
I have no memory of this. Just for the record.
Maybe I have a fake memory. You know why?
I'll tell you why.
Okay, there is nothing wrong with breaking down gender stereotypes.
I wanted to dress up as her. Okay? She was my favorite character.
[Laughs]
Don't judge me!
So I remember going to school with uh that hair cut.
[Laughs]
I must have been like three years old like...
[Windows powering down sound]
[Silence]
[High pitched steam sound]
"Post with 10k upvotes and has nothing to do with PewDiePie."
"My downvote."
I kinda like that the Subreddit is not just about me.
I don't mind that at all.
"Have someone make an addiction where they're obsessed with PewDiePie."
"Go on Dr. Phil."
"Dr. Phil shows PewDiePie's content."
"PewDiePie copy strikes Dr. Phil."
"Sony: Wait a minute... That's illegal."
What if I and talk only about my G fuel addiction.
[Ding]
Glug Glug Glug Glug Glug.
10% off with code PewDiePie.
Can I copy strike myself?
This
Rain
bo ooooooooooooow
issss
stttttttiiiiccckkk
releeeevant
[Windows powering down sound]
[Clock ticking sound]
What is it minus or is it connected?
It's a rainbooooww...
[Clock ticking sound]
This gaaaayy
mmmm
This game is....
[Clock ticking sound]
Why am I so slow? Come on.
I can do this.
Staaaa
[Clock ticking sound]
Is it fine? I don't get it?
[Clock ticking sounds]
Is....... is it sick?
Relevant goddamn.
[Clock ticking sounds]
It.
[Laughs]
[Clock ticking sounds]
THIS GAME IS STILL RELEVANT GOD DAMN IT.
[Laughs]
I'm so dumb!
Oh no! I'm so... oh... I'm stupid!
Oh no I'm so stupid!
I'm a dummy dumb.
I'll always be dumb.
Don't hurt me.
I'm so stupid.
I can't help it.
Please.
[Fake crying shriek]
"Hi guys. I'm a thirteen year old nine year old ehhh."
Wh-what the- what did I just read?
I'm a thirteen year old nine-
[Windows powering down sound]
"I've saved up $400 for this chair and now I finally have it..."
"...I'm not rich or even close to it, but this is my own money that I worked hard for. Thanks."
They need help assembling it. I'll come over.
[Laughs]
It looks like you're having some trouble there.
If you want a good chair and want to support me at the same time.
I do very very very very much appreciate it.
I hope one day I can give back in a better way then...
...then what I've been doing.
"Stop dating boys who don't understand this."
Jesus Christ, another one?
Guys, I can't do this.
Exit your...
I don't like when it says "N" that makes me scared.
What does the "N" mean?
Exit your nnnnnnnnnnn
[Clock ticking sounds]
Tree?
Your?
[Clock ticking sounds]
Your nnn tree in?
Subreddit?
[Clock ticking sounds]
Brofist and?
What the hell?
It's too hard I can't do it.
[Laugh] [Clock ticking sounds]
Exit your?
What is that? It's a tree!
[Clock ticking sounds]
Your and
Entry.. exit.. your entry.. entry.. that's what it is!
[Clock ticking sounds]
In...
Leave your entries in the subreddit bros and!!!!
I'll!!!
[Laugh] [Triumphant music]
Watch submissions in the next episode of LWIAY!!
[Laugh]
I'm dumb.. I'm so stupiddd
Noooo
[Laugh]
5,000 IQ. I am the smartest man.
I- I am the smartest there has ever been smart.
Don't question my power, for I will destroy all of you.
PewDiePie!
Can we go there like a party!
That looks delicious.
Whoah!
[Music]
That looks sick!
Paper bag head! 10/10 dude!
Damn, that's so cool.
Whoah!
Heck yea! Sure! Ricon style baby!
"I am so sorry."
[Silence]
Well, it's time to end that episode there.
Thank you guys so much for all the lovely support and epic-ness
And creativity.
Smash like, subscribe, bro fist at 100 million, bro fist to God, and I'll see you guys next time! BYE!
Tuber simulator
It's now so relevant that it's got a brand new mini game Craniac!
Drop the crane and get fresh items only available in the washing machine like game !
And you say there's more?
Of course there is!
New knowledge perks, new quests, and new pixalinks and legs... guys.
Legs.
[Music]